[Narrator] Hi, I'm Kathleen and Sebastian wrote a piece of code for you
that I am now going to demonstrate.
So, the main class is a class called robot.
This robot lives in a 2-dimensional world of size 100 meters X 100 meters.
It can see 4 different landmarks that are located at the following coordinates:
20, 20; 80,80; 20,80; 80,20.
So, here's how we make such a robot.
It's really easy.
All you have to do is call a function robot() and assign it to a variable myrobot.
So, now that we can do things with myrobot.
For example, we can set a position.
These 3 values are the X coordinate, the Y coordinate, and the heading in radians,
and this command assigns those values to the robot.
So, let's print these things out
and down here you see the output
X=10, Y=10, and heading=0.
Next, let's make the robot move. This robot moves 10 meters forward and doesn't turn.
So, let's print the resulting position.
And here we go, you can see that it's now at 20, 10, and 0.
It moved 10 meters forward from 10,10 to 20,10.
Now, let's make the robot turn by pi/2 and move 10 meters.
So, now the robot is heading in the direction of pi/2,
and it moved forward 10 meters in the Y direction, instead of the X direction.
So, as you can tell it's really easy to program.
The last thing I want to show you is how to generate measurements.
There's a really easy command called sense()
and all it does is give you the distance to the 4 landmarks, 1, 2, 3, and 4.
For now this is all you need to know about the class robot
that Sebastian has programmed for you.
You might want to spend some time familiarizing yourself with the code
to see how this is all configured.